e
little unal this morning just because
there aren't a lot of people in the room
if you guys would make my life easier
and just sit at one of the seats over
here with a mic in front of you we can
just have a conversation just you know
can so we keep order but otherwise that
way we don't have to bounce around all
all right so we're starting the morning
looking at at uh SB
437 and uh Mr chairman you wanted to
share a few things to start so if you
want to get the conversation rolling we
can go from there thank you Mr chair so
just to sort of give us the lay of the
land this this bill really deals with
two issues one is the fact that
municipalities were supposed to be
sending their amendments to the bcrb for
for informational purposes for a long
time now four and I think maybe now five
have done that out of the 100 plus that
enforce the building code clearly that
was not working um all this bill does is
hold their feet to the fire and say
everybody send them to us if it was a
legal ordinance when you passed it
you're good to go we just check the
boxes and no problem no must no fuss
there's simply a clock in there to get
them to send it to us um the other thing
this deals with is if I can real quick
and if they don't do that within 60 days
they can't enforce it right right and
what happens next is up for grabs I
guess but well so in other words
somebody's building something it doesn't
live up to the code that they were right
um trying to enforce and then the
builders offs Scot free as far as they
can't be fined they can't be anything
like that because they haven't put this
through the building code guess that's
the outcome of it okay that's how I read
it but I just want to so part one of
this bill is to deal with getting the
municipalities to send those amendments
to the bcrb we check the boxes and
they're good to go provided they were
legal
ordinances um we just had an appeal that
turned out that they never had an
ordinance to create a building code
board of appeals so there's a lot of
those kinds of things out there I
suspect and this will flush some of that
to the surface uh the second thing that
this deals with is uh at least two
municipalities Portsmouth and Durham
have adopted later additions of the
model codes which are in the State
Building Code um and in fact Steve
reports that now both of them have
ordinances that basically say we just
adopt the new code we haven't read it
yet and it hasn't even published yet but
the day it's published it's in effect in
our town um it my understanding is from
2002 when the State Building Code was
created that was never the intent the
wording in the r RSA that allows towns
to adopt codes that are not otherwise in
the state code was put there to allow
them to adopt things like Property
Maintenance and housing codes so things
that the state code doesn't even deal
with not later additions of the codes
that are in the in the state code uh it
really comes down to do you want a
Statewide building code or do you not
because once a town or municipality can
do that all bets are off uh anybody can
adopt anything they want basically so
this tries uh to nail that down and it
was very difficult language to get our
arms around uh to prohibit them from
adopting later additions but still
preserving the right to adopt a property
maintenance or housing code and others
here have been involved in the process
uh longer than I have and may have a
have a different flavor on this but this
really comes down to those two issues
getting the municipal amendments
submitted and prohibiting the model
codes from you know being updated within
the municipality so this would be why we
changed the language uh let's say in
line four and line five from provisions
and regulations to amendments you're TR
you're trying to use that language to
attach it to a specific code that the
state board has passed there we need to
remember that much of the language
that's kicking around particularly in
the 674
series was kicking around before there
was a State Building Code MH so and 47
RSA 47 colon 22 is is a prime example
that language goes back what maybe the
1700s a long time anyway and it just was
before the before the days of modern
codes and you know well you can adopt
very broad language rather than you can
adopt a code uh so there was some sort
of housekeeping on the terminology as as
we went through this you're correct cor
okay
um you may have answered this uh line
six the language that says and this
comes up throughout the bill intended to
replace is that on page one uh page one
line six yes than so it gives three
caveats right every time it's it can't
be not inconsistent with or less
stringent than nor intended to replace
and the nor intended to replace is meant
to
capture so there's two ways to adopt the
later addition of a code just say we
adopt the later addition or submit you
know 400 amendments that just change
every section that changed in the new
code so that was the thing that was very
difficult to get our arms around and we
put that in there it's obviously a
subjective term um although maybe not if
it ever went to Discovery uh but that's
that's what that's trying to trying to
do okay
yeah there was language further down I'm
that maybe talk to that
too okay so you're so you're putting
that you're putting that language in and
then basically trying to backtrack that
which seemed like the more contentious
part of the bill or not not even
contentious but the one that raised some
concern um on the model codes no on
going back and andfor foring that on
okay at a time when it was legal for
them to do it but you had mentioned
something earlier that caught my
attention um so I was going to ask the
question Durham and and Dober I believe
correct Durham and Portsmouth Portsmouth
so they passed they passed code during
that that open window before it was
effective was part of that what you just
mentioned which is that they
automatically update to the current code
they did that during that time I I know
that was the case with Durham and Steve
says that's not a case with Portsmouth
as well Portsmith did yeah when they
updated they specifically updated a lot
of the codes but the electrical code
they said were adopting the newest code
going forward they don't even know what
it says and they and they did that in in
that open window yeah so that's what
we're trying okay that's much more
serious I was going to say if they were
because we had testimony during the
hearing that um with the issuance of new
adopted code like we just adopted new
code that those codes would become obs
Delite and they head after for renew but
not if they've not if they've adopted
we're just accepting new code if if we
don't have as as it comes out page two
it talks about the that uh reset so to
speak on July 1 yeah so yes that's what
happens any of those codes that adopted
in that Gap technically would be able to
stay because there was something in that
said any existing on so this is a reset
for the Fire Marshall and his staff be
able to log everybody in every town and
City and everybody start over so if you
don't have that it it creates an issue
for those two that went in or one that
went in in that six- Monon Gap trying to
to beat that and adopting it going
forward
so that was what Senator Carson was
concerned about was you know they had
the six month when the codes are adopted
they get adopted in July and they give a
six-month period to follow either code
the old or the new and during that
period is when they um they just said
we're just going to adopt the new code
immediately when it comes out they went
through the process they adopted a lot
of building codes and updated them and
then in there they adopted it on the
electrical side saying they're going to
adopt the 2026 code already hasn't even
been printed so yeah so that was part of
the concern part of the concern we
raised with Senator Carson was you know
that was just trying to get around it
that wasn't the intent so this just kind
of makes everybody start over from
square one and again it's just trying to
make them follow the existing law that
is required now and has been for years
to to adopt amendments not that Smith or
Dober didn't follow that but you know
it's uh so so was was consideration I'm
I'm starting to understand this much
better now um and it's a little bit more
serious than I thought it was
initially have did was consideration
given when drawing up the language as
opposed to doing the whole adopted to
Prior uh to July 1st 2024 whatever um
just saying that municipalities local
governing authorities can't wholesale
adopt code like can't they just can't
adopt code to that level because that
would address the major concern without
it appearing like you're going back and
doing something retroactively if you
look at line 10 on page one you see us
referencing the same or similar scope
yeah and that's that was an attempt to
say one you know from addition to
addition the scope is either the same or
it's pretty darn similar but also there
are alternative building codes there are
alternative plumbing and mechanical
codes that are published some are used
in the Western United States main and
Massachusetts use an alternative goes
way back but it uses an alternative
plumbing code um so similar scope no you
can't go grab another plumbing code just
because you like that one better than
the one the state has um it's imperfect
language we grappled with it a lot and
if somebody's got a way to tie it down
tighter that would be
good but also one of the things we did
with if I may the wording in there the
similar scope most codes have a scope in
the front of their code telling what it
is so we're not making up the scope it's
printed in that book so someone comes
with another one and it's the exact same
scope well then it's pretty obvious that
they're trying to adopt an entirely
different code from that right because
whereas if it doesn't have the same or
similar scope then it it makes sense for
what they're trying to look at so is
that is that the technical term
scope but in some section one of most of
the codes it's titled scope or purpose
that's why we put that that that would
make sense okay we to find that to make
sure that that was something that was
referenced in each one for the most part
to try to so it's not the State Building
Code ass siging if your scope similar
it's it's right there in the front of
the cover you open up the page two and
it's usually says it or something so
okay yeah no that's I mean I I would
agree that I think that is as long as
that's what that's the terminology
that's used that it would make sense to
use that language
here but that would be that would be a a
different scope then there's what you do
use for review right and you adopt the
building code or the fire code you are
using a set of um we have eight codes
within the building code right so does
that does that does that keep them
though from adopting a future code from
the same organization that you're using
that
language same organization or any other
organization and that's the intent
whether we've got it right or not time
will
tell well only to only to say that there
there will be um people staying up
nights trying to find ways around this
no I agree and I well that's what has me
concerned on that on the bottom of page
two and the top of Page Three
is is whether or not the language that's
being used uh I'm sorry what was your
name again sir bill yeah yeah um that
the concern that you brought up I I
share that concern with the with the
language as it's written here and I
don't want to give it maybe a little bit
of thought to see if we could come up
with something a little bit different um
because it seems like as it's written
you're doing retroactive law which is
against the Constitution which I think
could open you up to lawsuit I agree
with that I have some concern I had some
concern when I initially read it and if
I did somebody else is going to think
about it and and potentially go after it
when really what I think is trying to be
accomplished and correct me if I'm wrong
is that you just don't want people
adopting wholesale code two years ahead
of what you've adopted so if you there
two two parts to that though one is what
you just said yeah but the other is
there are amendments that are not
amendments floating around out there
this is what I I like in my town just go
do it a town that's using the zba as a
board of appeals but never had an
ordinance to do that which is what we
just found on an appeal that came to us
uh so if somebody has a legally adopted
ordinance and that if there's a
technical requirement it's at least as
stringent not less string not less
stringent we use funny words there than
the state code which has been in the law
now since there's been a state code
check the box and off they go no problem
at all take us 30 seconds to review it
yes Mr Timmy I think the the backwards
part of it in my head is just trying to
we've been asked for the last few years
to compile a list of these are the state
codes building or fire these are the
state amendments building or fire and
then all by the way here's who where you
can find the local amendments and as
I've described it's like a hide-and-seek
game right now to try to figure out what
conquer has what Manchester has what
Berlin has and you know we've only got
four or five right now um I don't know
how we without being retroactive right
that's the challenge how do we get the
communities to
submit the local amendments and then
give us the opportunity just to vet them
to make sure they were properly adopted
at the local level and they're not in
conflict with the code I think that's so
that's this part two of that I think may
be a little bit challenging I mean and
in our from Department safety
perspective I think it's up to you guys
on how you want to
do can the portsmiths and uh durhams
just wholesale adopt the the later the
21 or now maybe coming up on the 24
codes when we're still a cycle behind
which which for years now we're saying
we want to stay a code cycle behind and
then there's a couple communities that
going further out so like I think
the the general feeling I think from
industry is to stop that behavior right
don't don't jump ahead we we we've all
agreed the code processor should be one
cycle behind so we can vet it properly
and then the flip to that is that I've
been hearing is there's an ask to be a
One-Stop shop so I can understand if I'm
building in New Hampshire whether I'm a
homeowner trying to build a deck or do
some electrical work at my house or I'm
building the new parking garage and
there's an architect that's out of state
then come and find these are all the
this is where I need to go for New
Hampshire I just worked with a uh
architect out of
Ohio uh very good architect that solid
on the building code but missed that we
had the fire code um and uh we we
stumble into that a lot so if we can
create that One-Stop shop where
everything is for the design
professionals and everything else I
think that's would make it a lot easier
for the end user that's yeah no no and I
appreciate both of the comments that you
made and and I think I mean I can't
speak for my colleagues but I mean it
makes a lot of sense to me
um when we instituted the building code
the State Building Code obviously we're
overriding local code at that point so
the state has precedent that it can
override local code we can do that um
but now there is state code in place and
so now we've got this
interesting interaction between state
code and local code that wasn't the
dynamic when we put the code the state
code in place the first time so that's a
new Dynamic to it
so I'm just wondering if there's
language that we can
use that would simply
State um the expectation that any local
code regardless of When It Was Written
now needs to be brought before the
building code review board for approval
regardless as opposed to
specifying a certain group of people at
a certain time in this little
window I just think that that opens you
up in a way that maybe isn't necessary
we may be able to find a different way
to write it and get the same result and
to my two colleagues that are here if
you have other thoughts or different
perspective on this Chim INE at any time
um I'll recognize you for that but um
yeah I just so when you talking about
the retroactive chair are you talking
about the July 1 issue or the is that on
line page two line 27 27 through Page
yeah that whole section there
so and and I I completely understand
what you're what you're saying is trying
to make sure that it's no matter what
and we thought that that was kind of
accomplishing that so that everybody has
to resubmit it if you if you submitted
it prior to July 1 and we picked that
because we thought legislation would be
done possibly the bill would be signed
that that would be the the say okay here
we go here's a reset button so the Fire
Marshall can get everybody on board and
do that it wasn't we weren't trying to
be
um leaning to one side or the other you
know prejudice against one side or the
other it in a lot of the towns who have
some stuff in there I don't know how
many I'm not going to they've don't I
don't know something all realize the
process they need to go through to
legally adopt an amendment so for years
they've been doing this right and then
all of a sudden in in the previous
wording it stated that anything prior to
that stays in place so that defeats the
whole bill if we leave that now if
there's different wording absolutely
agree but that was what that was
intended to do is kind of give us a
reset so I'm not sure if it does but
yeah yeah no I understand and another
item that we've discovered
is these towns that had had maybe
adopted their local ordinances back
under the 674
regulations they don't go back and
review whether those amendments are in
conflict with state code at this point
now they continue to enforce or
administer those amendments but I've
often and even with my community gone
back to look at the Amendments that
we've had prior and discovered that that
whole section of code has moved so now
I'm referencing the wrong section in
code so every three years any community
that has amendments should be going
through to review all of their
amendments that they propose and
resubmit them to the build and code
review board it just makes the most
sense and that way there you aren't in
code have you got have you got
thanks
P have you got the
capacity with your Manpower and your
working hours and so forth to do all
that
Statewide review of individual
communities I I think so and and the
fire marshal is going to throw something
at me if I speak here uh I don't think
that the time involv D with these is
excessive okay um we've been through
several of them uh amher for instance
added a technical Amendment on water
quality very straightforward you could
review that in a couple of minutes Kanan
we worked with in detail because they
had this mishmash between zoning and
building stuff from back in the day that
took a little more time but many of
these will just be go sorted out and
come back to us uh so I I don't think
it's a lot of time and furthermore this
process is going to get rid of a lot of
that stuff they're going to look at it
and say it's out of date don't even
submit it we don't need it
anymore
I if I could add one other point yeah
please this is back on the later edition
of the model codes uh Med kinsky who's
the municipal association's
representative on our board reports that
he's had calls from six municipalities
looking to do what Durham and Portsmouth
have done and it's all part of this
energy code tussle so I think this is
the time we've somehow got to get our
arm around this or just cash in a state
building code and go back to the
do if I may Mr chair every town before
was using different Boer codes and
different building codes so it was crazy
to to figure out who was following what
and and you know like he said you get
into some towns I testified early at the
committee with the inspector even though
I proved that I was following the code
and was right he still said well this is
what I
want how are we supposed to run a
business and do the work when you know
you you get that interjected someplace
so this make sure it goes through the
proper process it's a it's a um what do
you call board um neutral board that is
made up of experts as opposed to to one
person in the town going this is what I
think is best keep in mind our building
inspectors for the most part some are uh
qualified in um going
through requirements but nothing in the
state requires them to have any
qualifications some of them don't know
anything about electrical or Plumbing
mechanical and they're telling us what
to do and we have to go there and show
them the Code prove to them and then
they still say well this is what I want
so it's trying to fix that a little bit
too but it gives you an appeal process
at that point you can go to the building
code review board and say it hasn't been
submitted properly so you can't enforce
it exactly right now we'd have to take a
legal process which is expensive so you
just do it whereas now we could go to
the board if I go and I get a permit now
right if this was in place and I go and
I get a permit and they say hey here's a
list like in pelam they have a list that
you get with your permit of what he
wants okay I go I pull up the website on
the State Building because it's been
logged I see they have it on there and
all those are there or not if not I at
least have some legal ground to say Hey
look it's not posted have you fought
follow proper procedure it gives us some
some help to deal with that that's right
it might not help it might not help the
one guy who's doing some work in his
home and they come in and say something
because he doesn't know the code but
it's going to help larger construction
all these projects all the working
Workforce housing I mean this there's a
lot there's a lot of that have the
little little quirks and it's tough
it'll help everybody who who knows this
stuff essentially trying to be
consistent that's all well all I'm
saying is that a local enforce
enforcement agent would be able to go in
and maybe pressure somebody to adopt
code that wasn't required because they
didn't know the individual who's doing
the work might not know that it had to
go through the state you know building
code review board so they're not going
to be able to appeal it and in that case
they're they're going to get away with
enforcing code that's too stringent or
you know whatever and also if they
didn't follow the process say they're
just saying I want this they're they're
enforcing something illegally
technically because it didn't pass
that's something that's been in the laws
for forever we found out about that they
have to go through a town process
whatever that municipality is to get it
approved they can't just say here's a
sheet here's what I want so this helps
here's here's an aspect of this that I
hadn't thought about
um we've probably got about 20 more
minutes on on this one um we'll have to
have another morning anyway but say
there's uh a homeowner
um who is doing a renovation project at
their house or you know whatever the
case may be with a small contractor who
doesn't really understand the
interaction between the local code
Authority and the building code review
board at the state we pass
this say the local um code
enforcer requires that the Builder um
use code
that's that hasn't gone to the building
code review board for acceptance right
so it's not technically legal the owner
has to spend an extra $110,000 on the
project to meet that code that wasn't
legal and then on the back side they
find out that it wasn't a legal code
because it hadn't gone to the building
code review board is is there now civil
action available to that person to
recoup from the town or whoever the code
agency was working for to to recoup that
$10,000 from the town because they were
illegally enforcing a code because they
not I'm not a lawyer um so that would
answer somewhere beyond the code process
outside of the code process uh but you
you may be right I might note that
Connecticut mucked around with this
several years ago and actually made the
building inspector person Ally liable if
they required anything that wasn't in
the code they got rid of that in a hurry
because it just caused I think so much
harassment um but there's always an
ability at the court level to come after
somebody that caused you harm yeah I
mean it seems like it it seems like it
would because we're saying it's illegal
and they're doing something illegal just
just curious building inspectors are
indemnified from from lawsuits and and
legal action except in cases of gross
negligence so in this case here if an
attorney if it's civil suit is filed and
they can argue that by you know
knowingly enforcing a code that's not
adopted by the state and we have this
Statute in place with the language that
says you can't do that then I think you
could make the argument that that was
gross negligence and then the the
inspector himself would be Li maybe not
the town
okay yeah and just to add on to that
let's say they did it before this passed
they still that homeowner still has that
right and could go after that legally
it's just going to be a longer process
because it didn't go through and show
that they didn't follow they may not
know what they really have to do as
municipality to be legally adopted so
even now they if they didn't follow that
process that homeowner still would have
that but the Avenue is obviously more
expensive and you get caught in the
middle of I want my CEO or I'm going to
fight this for a year and not be able to
move into my house and that's right what
happen so yeah that makes sense okay um
real quickly anything from the committee
members
okay
um oh uh just a couple notes that I made
um there's no need to reference RSA 153
in this at all there's nothing that
would hit 153 that doesn't hit 155
wouldn't have to go before the building
code review board we we've got the line
at the very bottom that says that
everything's going to have to go by the
State Fire Marshal for verification that
there's no conflict with the fire code
but there's nothing that would arise
independent of that is there yes Mr
chairman we tried to cover the fire code
as it applies to RSA 47 for
cities the 674 series only applies to
the building code anyway um so 153 sort
of sat the way it is okay so 47
addresses 153 I didn't I didn't see it
specific I don't know it well enough is
my understanding and Sean and I have
talked about this is that cities have
the ability to to amend the fire code
through RSA 47 towns do not currently
have the Legal Trail to be able to amend
code right so that's that's you're
talking about the last line there Phil
when you're saying uh 32 of of the
entire Bill 32 of Page Three you're
saying that reference there to 4722 you
think is
enough to cover to cover everything
having to do with the fire code
tried to do that others a to review it
make sure we got it right but yeah we
take another look but I think we
captured it but to Phil's Point there's
a little I've asked the AG's office to
look in the path for town to adopt
changes and I'm still waiting to hear
back on them right now but okay that
one's a little vague
um I'm just trying to find we found
another spot in 155a it talks about
State Building and the fire code mhm um
quick in 155a which is a State Building
Code it also in the definitions talks
about the state fire code and points it
back to 1531 so
in we believe it captures it both there
rather than having a point in two
different directions sure
but okay well a little I'll take a yeah
I'll take another look at it too and if
I think there's concern I'll run stuff
by you guys before the next subcommittee
when we move it out of here perfect um
but I just I noticed that and just
wanted to make sure that we didn't need
to reference 153 at all and then uh
there is the question and we can talk
about it with the few minutes we've got
left on this bill um
page one yes page one lines 24 to
29 there's a conflict with HB 1387 in
the language because 1387 actually
repeals this section
um and my question to everybody is if we
get rid of that language in this bill is
that going to cause any problems to the
overall concept or
not because if we allow it to be
repealed and then we just take that
language line 24 through 29 out of this
bill completely so that it no longer
exists is that going to weaken this
language and make it unworkable sure
just for the record 1387 proposes to
repeal this section right which would
leave this here all this is is a flag to
other rsas it's not critical that it be
there or not be there uh we just wanted
to make sure this bill didn't get mucked
up if 1387 got passed first right okay
so if there's I would prefer and I can
talk to Howard Pearl about it and make
sure that we do it in a timely way that
makes sense but I would prefer to leave
the repeal in and then just take 24 to
29 out of this bill through an amendment
and then it's not going to mess with the
nobody's going to not pass this bill
because that's taken out
it yeah um we we had reached out to
actually have him do it the opposite
take the repeal out of 1387 and leave
this alone is what we were we felt was a
better fix I don't know if you're okay
with that or not well the only reason
why I say do the other way is it takes a
lot of stuff out of Statute if it
doesn't need to be in there if it's not
accomplishing anything um I'd rather
take the duplicative language out with
through the repeal and then not have to
have this being referenced it would just
take two sections out of Statute that
arguably don't need to be there and so
my question is I would rather take two
pieces out that don't need to be there
if they don't need to be there rather
than leave them in and have them be
unimportant so my question is whether or
not this is important to the bill
because I'm not seeing how it is
important to the bill but if you do see
how it is then
I'm because of referencing this is the
reference to 67451 and
4722 I believe those go through and
explain the procedures that counties
towns and cities must go through in in
order to adopt an amendment to the State
Building Code so yeah so I think I think
it's kind of important to direct them to
make sure that they know that if if
you're amending the State Building Code
in any way towns have to follow the
process and
67451 and cities have to follow the
process in
4722 but yeah my my point is doesn't
67451 and 4722 already articulate that
on their own like if you go to
674 and read that doesn't it already
articulate articulate and in fact you
can look up at the bill above it uh
right from the beginning the local
legislative body in 674 May enact as an
ordinance right which is essentially
what that's saying down below or adopt
pursuant to the procedures so it's
lining out that you need the ordinance
already in place in order to pass any
amendments to the building code which is
what we would be doing in this bill um
so that delineates that are you
concerned mostly just about um delinting
counties towns cities and Village
districts specifically as opposed to
local legislative
bodies because I don't believe cities
are captured in are cities captured in
675 no it it would be captured in 4722
though correct so that's so that order
what I'm saying is I think that RSA
stands on its own like it already says
to a city or town you have to go through
uh you know applicable uh ordinance in
order to adopt new code so if both of
those sections of RSA already say you
need an ordinance to adopt the code I'm
not sure why we would need this
reference to tell them to go look at
those places to adopt an ordinance to
adopt the
code but
yes my personal view of this is I think
it's a convenience but it's not critical
because as you said those two sections
stand on their own um we have some
people looking at whether we can pull
some of this stuff into
155a so it's all in one place that's an
exercise for another year it's fairly
complicated uh but I think this is just
a convenience right now and it's not
necessary
okay yes uh I think 674 51a is specific
to so the municipal municipality May
adopt by reference any of the codes
prated by the ICC and shorten it which
are not included in the State Building
Code so I think that was the uh that
talks about like the property
maintenance code and those types of
things that's what 51a talks
about 51a we're proposing we just repeal
it because it's mostly duplicative of
other stuff so that we have I guess the
concern would be is if
we is it clear enough somewhere else
that someone could still do the property
maintenance code or something for using
that it's an
example yeah I think we tried to cover
that in page one line 8 n and so forth
so the local legislative body May adopt
a nationally recognized code not
included in not in inconsistent with so
forth yeah it makes sense
okay yeah that makes sense yeah so we're
we're feeling okay about that I don't
want to screw up the bill that's all I'm
saying we can do that right would you be
willing to give us afterwards we'll just
make sure that yeah yeah um like I said
I'm gonna we probably got a week before
I've got to finalize it but I will have
to get an amendment put together for
that meeting so I'd need a few days so
like if you guys want to get back to me
with any concerned by the end of the
week my only other concern is I've got
to do this in conjunction with Howard
poral over in the Senate because he's
going to be doing stuff over there so
I've got to ask him to hold off until at
least Friday or whatever but if you get
it to me after that then I can work with
him and we can get the language right
and and get it in time for an amendment
to if by chance they were executing that
today and they were trying to do that
would you be able to fix that still
because well if he does that I'll just
do it the other way so if if the repeal
goes like if they get rid of the repeal
we'll just we'll just leave it as it is
okay yeah so if I don't get to them in
time it's no big deal I'm just trying to
clean up statute if you if you're if
you're in the habit which I'm sure
everybody here is of weeding through
statute all the time the less is more
you know like
it's it's just a pet peeve of mine over
the last four years so
um perfect anything else from anybody
time only that this is a difficult set
of stuff it's hard to understand makes
your eyes roll back but it really
addresses two critical problems whether
we have a Statewide building code or not
and this whole issue of local amendments
and whether we can find them and that
they're legal so I would just hope that
that the entire committee and then on to
the other appropriate bodies uh gets
this thing through but thank you for for
looking at it absolutely and I
understand this way better so I
appreciate you guys coming in and and
talking me through it cuz um there are
stuff that I just wouldn't have picked
up on just reading it so that's that's
very helpful to me um you you mentioned
that though and it did bring up one more
question that I just wanted
clarification on um you had mentioned
you can do it two ways you can either
adopt a future set of the code right
later date um or you could just pass 400
little amendments in order to get
yourself there
how does this close that loophole what
what particular part of language are you
looking to close that loophole I
understand the code like the overall
just adopting whole code but the death
by death by 400 Cuts so our languag is
on page one line 12 the intent of this
restriction shall not be avoided by the
adoption of local amendments as
determined by the billing code okay so
that's the section that you're looking
to do that with all right I I know
that's going to cause us trouble but
maybe this balloon will float to the
surface quickly and we'll fix it once
and that'll SLE it so okay and so just
once again for my own
edification two things that you're
trying to accomplish one old code that
isn't that doesn't meet the requirements
of this legislation because it's it's
less restrictive than our current code
that's been floating out you want to
flush that stuff out or a properly
adopted ordinance that's the bigger
issue okay and then obviously because
that's that's the one side of the one
side of the issue and the other is
restricting what they can do to adopt
more restrictive code to one degree or
at least having to come through the
building code review board and not being
able to do it holistically like just as
the codes have gotten into energy and to
a degree accessibility and some of the
the things that drift a little bit away
from Pure safety what's more res what's
more stringent gets harder and harder to
to think
about because it might require more here
but less there that kind of thing so
okay great thank you gentlemen very much
appreciate
it we will let you know when the next
one
is at least 24 hours
notice and I was I was 25 hours on this
one
so yeah no I'll try to post a days this
yeah
e
um this amendment basically just
clarifies that uh they're leaving um
written testimony open for seven days
and not spoken testimony because that
seems like a bad idea
um just does um so that's basically what
it does in the original bill it said
seven days and it kind of left it vague
in fact it almost seemed the opposite
seemed like you had to submit written
testimony immediately but you had 7 days
to give verbal testimony um so this just
reverses that and the original language
is at the bottom of page two and the top
of Page Three on the actual bill so
representative boy is looking at that
any concerns from the other committee
members who have had a chance to peruse
that language I don't if this
works seems like seems like a good idea
it's I don't think generally that do I
have to say my name for the record no
okay I don't think generally for the
record you wouldn't us to be sitting at
so I don't think we really put a cap on
written testimony I think people can
just submit things to the boards
whenever they want so I uh even with
this language in place we would probably
time I don't know I would possibly
disagree with that because any public
hearings for uh rules that go to jard it
says you know the written comment is
requested by a certain date they have a
deadline so I think this stays
consistent with it and again it wasn't
meant for them to have seven days to
have public comment spoken that was
never really the intent I think Doug
caught it it was it was a good catch and
it was meant to have seven days to send
it in so and uh so I was speaking just
kind of in general but for rules we
usually keep it open for 10 days anyway
okay just as a general practice so is
there a reason why we wouldn't switch
this to 10 days to be consistent would
it be best to stay consistent just keep
that it's an
easy that language was just there
so if that would keep it consistent with
everything else keep cons well I I don't
know cuz like is it oh that's an
interesting is it like a 10 business day
vers versus S calendar day I haven't
done the math in my head I don't have a
strong opinion on that either way and we
do generally keep the record open for 10
days and and if it's timely sometimes
we'll even accept it after that time
period if we can still act on it okay so
sure the best my knowledge is 10 days
because they literally give you the DAT
so if the public hearing is April 10th
they tell you by April 20th so it does
they don't really get into business or
calendar days yeah they just give it the
10 days and it would make sense I think
to keep it consistent then we wouldn't
be trying to guess if you went to public
hearing as opposed to another yeah and I
think if the if the requirement was
seven days and we're doing 10 anyway
probably just as a matter of policy
stick with that 10 so it's probably not
going to make a difference okay so if
it's not going to make a difference we
might as well keep it consistent for
everybody else who isn't oplc and
doesn't know these things sure all
right there's what you're going to do
and then there's if everybody knows that
what you're going to do is what you're
going to do so
um all right well we actually have uh
enough people here to act on things now
so that's good we started without that
now we have it um so we don't actually
have to have the official amendment in
subcommittee um you guys can just
authorize me to go get the official
Amendment uh for the full committee
um but we should we should we should
talk real briefly about the
overall legislation not just the
amendment but whether or not um the idea
of making sure that the public meetings
are notified no less than 14 calendar
days prior to the meeting uh everybody's
good with the actual substance of the
original bill um is anybody opposed to
the substance of the original
Bill okay so we seem good with that um
and then I would you know I think
probably the amendment is a good idea
but I'll entertain a motion from
369 representative Schmidt yeah okay we
are going to go to 10 yeah we're going
to go to 10 well you're making the
motion
sir yeah so we're going to go to 10 and
we're going to adopt the amendment the
langu the language of the
amendment okay very good do I have a
second all right Resa Davis all in
favor all right we got four Z on
that
all right we'll close up our time on 369
371 this is a fun
one actually once again I don't know I
feel like the RSA changed between the
last I don't even know what I was
looking at I made a couple comments and
I'm looking for the language in 32914
and I couldn't even find it so I think
yeah all right so um s SP
371 don't think do I have Amendment
language for this one for you guys I
don't think
so no I
don't representative yes I do did you
receive the email I sent you I did okay
yeah so there's two different compon
there's two different parts of this
there's the original intent of the
legislation and then there's all the
stuff that you said um we ran past the
speaker all of the other stuff that we'd
be considering is considered non gerain
so we'll have to hold a public hearing
which we might do I'm talking to the
chair about it um so really the in the
purpose of today's part of the
subcommittee meeting is just to talk
about the
um intention of the bill and whether or
not we agree with that um and also we'll
take a look at the amended language that
you've proposed and see how we feel
about
that and
um is the New Hampshire Hospital
Association here for this one yes did
us yes uh she said she was going to be
here but she seems to be running a
little bit behind so she's on her way is
she okay we'll wait for her then yeah no
worries you can give her a few minutes
we've got an hour so I don't think it'll
take us that long if she's going to be
more than an hour then the answer is now
all
right
e
um okay so
371 um the purpose of this is to create
a caveat for um resident Physicians um
from the
2-year um renewal process for for lure
um so that it would basically well
technically depending on what language
we go with would give oplc rule making
authority to designate how long those
licenses would be for um but for so for
right now uh it's every license has to
be renewed every two years and they're
looking for an exception to that
essentially um so we have uh everybody
got I passed around the amended language
yes okay so everybody has that
and I guess I would start the
conversation um directed to Dartmouth
and the hospital
Association um which I asked ahead of
time one of the questions that came up
at the public hearing um and I know will
be an issue um it's an issue for me as
well is what is the specific hardship
that's being created um so if you have
that information that would be great if
you wouldn't mind sharing it sure I'm
going to put my mic on yep yeah so thank
you so much for the questions ahead of
time because it allowed me opportunity
to connect with our medical staff office
so I'm a I'm a licensed attorney by
training and I have to renew my license
every year and so when the question was
asked of me I thought the same thing
like well wait a minute can't um these
individual people just renew their
license and take responsibility for it
but I was quickly corrected and reminded
that we have over
450 resident physician um providers who
are really the backbone of the providers
not actual resident Physicians resident
Physicians lenses who are who are
providers who are doctors and they're
really the backbone of the medical
center in terms of overnights on call
when you think about receiving Care at
an academic Medical Center you're
receiving robust care and really that's
because you're receiving care from res
training resident Physicians and so um
our resident Physicians are working well
over 80 hours a week they're doing those
odd hours you know nights weekends
holidays Etc and so the one thing we can
give them is administrative support and
to to um help them with their license
and I just want to um we are so grateful
for the work that was done on House Bill
655 last legislative session so thank
you to this committee all the work that
oplc did to really streamline licensing
um sincerely I mean we we we take all we
took it sincerely I was just responding
to duck space that's all I know you did
a lot of work but flash there are some
when we have a large over overhaul like
that sometimes there are pieces that we
just forget that should stay the same or
that could could stay the same and I
think this was just one of those that
just kind of fell through the cracks so
we're really just looking to ensure that
we can continue status quo and continue
to license these providers in that kind
of bundled way as opposed to
streamlining them in the every two-year
licensing processes so during the public
hearing you had mentioned in your
testimony that it could be up to seven
years but most licenses are three to
three to five three to five three to
five in particular um so we're looking
at maybe one to two renewals per
person yes over the over the term so as
opposed to just having it for the entire
length of their residence residency
their we may have to renew it once or
twice um because obviously the initial
one is going to be the initial one no
matter what we we do
um Mr
UT what does the renewal process look
like now under
oplc how long how long of a process is
it to renew a medical license what do
they have to do so typically uh we're
going to notify a licy 60 days out and
then they it varies from board to board
and we're working on consolidating that
process but there's a universal
application form under the PLC 400s that
has standard information name birth date
that type of stuff and then whatever the
board specific requirements are but once
you send that in and you get it to us um
we have to take a look at that within 30
days if there's any problems with it we
notify the applicant uh so they get a
chance to cure once we have a full
application and it typically comes in
right away that way um we can sometimes
get it done same day but I would say two
week stops
what I'm trying to gauge is how long
it's going to take the administrative
offices to fill out a renewal form I
know that the state has become very
streamlined in a lot of things and the
ones that I get for my business like the
licensing renewals are really easy at
this point um some of them take me
literally a minute to fill out and send
back in and so that's the other part of
the hardship that I'm just trying to
gauge from the hospitals perspective is
so you've got 450 but that's scattered
over how many institutions that's just a
dart that's just a Dartmouth our Medical
Center that's just Dartmouth yep so
that's just our Medical Center we also
have um resident training programs at
Cheshire and then I I can't I don't
represent the other hospitals but there
are programs across the state so Ben can
speak to the other programs yeah if you
would mind yeah so if you don't mind I'm
just
mik while Ben I'm G to give him some
Grace while he's digging out I just have
a couple things to to know so we um
we're in as of the summer of 2024 we're
going to have 462 lenses just at the
medical center and I just want to note
that um as as Doug has noted these are
rolling and so the renewals are going to
be done every other odd year I believe
but then we're every year we're going to
have resident trainees that are coming
in so for the administrative burden for
our Med Staff office is going to be
tracking those annually then tracking
which ones are are going to be renewed
every other year when did they start so
if somebody comes in in 2024 they're
going to have to be renewed in
2025 or 2027 so there's a there's a a
rolling process here where it would be
much more um it'd be much easier for us
frankly to um in license a resident for
the length of their residency as we do
in current
practice um so I got this from uh some
information about Portsmith hospitals
Residency program I do not have
conquered hospitals Residency program um
um there are eight Family Medicine
residents that are there for three years
um so a total of 24 Family Medicine
residents
[Music]
um you're speaking just a portion
yes that's right okay um and they just
established their program not too long
ago um so building upon
um appears there are 24
for
Psychiatry and 30 for Internal
Medicine uh from Portsmith Hospital okay
great
and I wonder if oplc would have an
official number at if you needed an
official number of how many lenses you
you're looking at and it I don't expect
that now we didn't really go over that
but you know to look at a full spectrum
the other I I mean the other important
question well first off does
subcommittee members have any questions
at this point before I keep bling on
okay
um has there been any harm done
because the two-year process would would
create some level of accountability to
review right I mean is there any harm
done by allowing the license to go for
as long as it has over the years that
it's been doing that it's my
understanding that there hasn't and um
there certainly are checks and balances
that are in place aside from licensing
including Insurance credentialing our
internal policies and procedures so I
would say that to answer your question
directly the net benefit including
supporting our Workforce streamlining
our business operations far out outweigh
any potential concern because there's
been no documented concern to dat if I
may too um Courtney am I mistaken that
previous to the five 655 bill um
residents were recognized for the term
of their residency it's just since the
two-year has been enacted so it's not a
foreign concept yeah that's why I was
saying historically have we had any
problem with that kind of Licensing
because it's a general rule of the aisle
is basically like heyy you know like
hands off as much as possible unless
Harm's being done sure so um and so
that's that's a good argument for me
personally is all I'm saying but yes
Peter thank you Mr chair so uh I I just
want to be sure that I understand so
typically as part of uh medical training
as I understand it is when they finish
medical school then they are eligible
for residency then they find a place
that is is uh interested in hiring them
uh and they are going to be then they
are they come on board they they are
going to be as part of their training
they're going to be practicing medicine
under the direct supervision right of uh
at least at the very beginning direct
supervision of a a a of a
mature uh Doctor Who
been doing this for years let's say okay
uh and and so they would then uh get a
license as part of the process we're
talking about um and that and that
license and their residency would last
for what three years we talking about
generally yeah it depends on the
duration of their residency as if we're
talking about the current practice how
we've done it here in New Hampshire it
depends on the duration of their
residency the Board of Medicine licensed
them for the the duration of their
residency so for example a family
practice um a family practice resident
um will have a residency for three years
a surgeon could have a a specialty
surgeon could have a residency for up to
seven years
right yes and you're right they do
practice under um supervision and
guidance of an attendee and their
license is a resident license right
right um the other thing to keep in mind
is given that the programs are three to
five to seven years kind of odd-numbered
years when you apply a license for two
years you've
essentially um afforded them the the
license of a residence for maybe an
additional year if you were to have to
renew every two years do you see what
I'm saying with the the way the math
Works um you start on year one if you
are expected to um fulfill a a um um
subsequent license for residency to
complete your last year that residency
license is good for two years it just
doesn't match up with the term of the
programs so that's the other thing that
makes it more in line with the way
things work for a Residency
ahead suppose a
resident doesn't finish their residency
in their skill what if they want to move
to another
hospital where they start over again did
they take a competency exam what's
what's the story and how would they how
would oplc deal with something like that
that is a great question I I'd have to
follow up with you on that question I
don't have all the answers it's a great
question I I I would just say that the
license is for that person um it's not
they're not licensed as a Dartmouth
Health Medical Center resident they're
licensed as a resident in New Hampshire
and so I would suspect that their their
resident license could be you know they
would carry that with them to Portsmith
or conquer where there's another
Residency program I don't you know
that's my guess but now let still
uh the people in
residency is it going to affect their
ability to take uh board
certification um I'm not sure about that
I mean everyone has to make individual
decisions right about where they they
work and then where they're going when
they're going to sit for their boards um
I'm not sure about that okay but they
would be licensed for that period for
that institution right so well they
their residency proper not there's
nothing on their license that says
they're a Dartmouth Hitchcock resident
it just says Jane Smith resident
physician license the the license just
just for clarification because I might
answer your question Peter in in statute
as soon as that agreement is terminated
so does the license
right but I mean that that's the idea
they would be coming on board uh at that
institution even if it doesn't say but
they would have some kind of a contract
for the institu for in this case for
Dartmouth But but so I'm I'm familiar at
least with the concept of residency but
uh but we're talk we also said
Portsmouth uh you said what and what did
you say about conquered Ben conquered
hospital they have a program too they
have a program to how about one with
Douglas in in Dober no um there are
other uh in there is interest in in
additional residency programs in the
future at various uh sites um I think
there was a proposal in
403 uh to create a Residency program in
the North Country um so you know the
idea is when you can bring providers out
of school to New Hampshire give them
that exposure to our state uh the hope
is they would stay and and be here and
we want to make it as easy for them as
possible
obviously it's a question to the
advantage of the institution to have the
workforce that they need because uh you
know for example I understand if you're
working kind of that's the you know not
as a stranger uh movie you know they're
working kind of Around the Clock it's
kind of like uh
grueling right but you need people at
all hours because people have accidents
there are crimes committed or you know
whatever Around the Clock you need to
have somebody there available at in the
middle of the night as well as work
business hours right so it's important
to have the people there uh and and and
Al also it's not like uh you have
something where you have a standard
practice somebody comes in whatever
their medical emergency is requires that
team uh to be working on them for as
long as it takes to stabilize them save
them whatever um and admit them and so
forth uh and that could be
for it it can't be limited to a specific
time period right they've got to be
there for that person as long as it
takes and if they're and longer
sometimes right Peter Peter to be fair
I've never heard a resident complain
work I have so
anyway I read it in a book years ago I
saw it in a movie years ago um but but
anyway the thing is that it's it's to
benefit of the institution to have
people available on in those under those
circumstances
uh but it's also uh to the advantage of
the individual practicing physician to
be able to have a place to go to and
continue their training program uh but
also they're making a living right off
the bat and so forth or getting paid for
it anyway and one additional element
representative the community the
community benefits from the well clear
clearly the community benefits from
having uh Hospital there that's one of
the reasons for example when the
question of the continuation of frisbee
Hospital uh as an institution there was
some talk of them
closing uh and I remember thinking you
know here's the community of Rochester
30,000 people roughly few thousand more
uh and over 10 11 miles away similar
population and suddenly the
Hospital frisbee potentially closing
down now all those people are suddenly
going to have to go 11 more miles uh to
come to Dover or go someplace else uh
for their treatment and that clearly
would not be in the interest of the
community bring it back to the point of
attack that you raised um but the thing
is uh so this is a traditional thing uh
but I I think of Dartmouth as a training
institution that's where they're
studying me medicine at Dartmouth uh but
we don't have a similar situation in
Portsmouth to my knowledge uh so they
would be and you said it's not happening
at at Wentworth Douglas uh it is
happening at conquer so um but I was not
aware of the fact that we were doing
residency uh in in Dover which is why I
asking you said that's a negatory um but
conquered and and yes yes okay uh but
it's a they come in and they would be at
that Institution for that period of time
uh and and presupposing that everything
is going well they'd be there for that
period and to have a license and a for
residency for that period would
obviously be advantageous and not have
to renew during that
period
again thank you Peter um yeah the ARG
can be made that it would be better for
anybody who's practicing to not have to
renew their license but
uh no I know I'm just playing with you
Peter um so one other question that I
have before we get into the kind of guts
of the bill itself to make sure that it
actually functions um fees
dug for this type of license
Anya I don't know off the top of my head
I'd have to look at the 102s but if it
was traditionally done so two comments
one if it was traditionally done the
other
way we probably wouldn't notice much
difference financially and I think the
other comment is and this would probably
come from the governor's office too uh
right licensing is for public protection
not for fee
generation you're speaking to my heart
tub yeah you've been with me long enough
I hear you just covering all the basis
well no because it was 200 bucks per
license it um it has they have to be
licensed right one way or the other have
to be licensed so the the license is
there for Public Safety but the cost of
it gets shifted to other people if it's
not being collected from one group it
has to cover the cost of the board so
it's going to be cover it's going to be
collected at 450 resident Physicians for
for Dartmouth if it were $200 you're
talking $90,000 every renewal cycle and
I think that's a really good point
because there are a lot of shared costs
right for disciplined prosecutors having
the hearings officers those kinds of
things and that wouldn't necessarily be
covered after that initial license now
again speaking not I'm not the fan
Finance guy but but that is a good point
to race if you could just get me that
information just so I have it that' be
helpful I'm not sure that it'll be a
determining Factor at all I just like to
have
it yeah so if we're going to have it for
three years instead of the typical
license so we're going to prate the uh
the cost for on the on the basis of
getting a longer license it's going to
cost more right I think we would have to
reflect on what's done been done in the
past um and maybe work with oplc to see
what that looks like but that's a that's
an that's an interesting idea though
Peter I hadn't thought about that that's
all I'm saying what do you what do you
think uh
Doug that's something I'd have to run by
Lindsay but potentially exist if we're
going to have to account for seven years
worth of time instead of two it it might
have to be
adjusted it's a good
point we're not going to have the same
price for two years as for three years
or seven years that that makes no sense
to not to me
anyway if I may it may just be wise to
take a look at how it had been done
historically yeah um yeah that's all
we're asking yeah no absolutely I mean
not not that people usually complain
about the pay at that once You' reach
that level but it would probably be I'm
I'm assuming Physicians and surgeons
would pick up the rest of the tab so
they'd be picking it up in their Futures
as opposed to in the present but um okay
so there's that component of it all
right so now if I may unless there's any
other comments on
the content of the bill or the intent of
the bill from the
subcommittee um if you want to look at
the draft legislation I I looked at this
for a bit this morning and I think um
what Doug's written up makes a lot of
sense
um basically in in number two it just
says that licenses shall be valid for
two years from the date of issuance
except for Physicians residency licenses
and Apprentice licenses for the two The
Apprentice licenses were already in this
section um we'd be adding The Physician
residency licenses to it the duration of
the physician residency licenses and
appr Apprentice licenses shall be
established by the office according uh
in accordance with 541a timely income
and it goes on from there um if we were
to go with this language Doug I had a
question right off the bat for you um
3294 what was
it
32945 C says this it says training
licenses shall be confir uh confined to
activities performed in the course of
the qualifying residency or graduate
Fellowship training program we'd want to
keep that shall expire automatically
upon licenses SE lenes separation from
The Residency or graduate Fellowship
training program for any reason it may
be issued on a restricted or conditional
basis so we would have that in
statute and you would also have rule
making
Authority would that that could
potentially be conflicting well we could
we could always Draft rules in
accordance with the statute okay so it'
be fine to to leave it there and then
that would be the guidance for you
setting it okay that's fine I just
wanted to make sure that we
weren't doing yeah Steve go
ahead yeah I think this is a little
confus the apprenticeship licenses now
we're talking about the electricians we
were talking about in the hearing is
that correct that is correct because
they're they're already in 310 8 as an
exception so they'd have to stay in 3108
as an exception we would just be adding
The Physician residency licenses to do
we want to put in apprentice license
electrician apprentice licenses do we
need to do that that or just we're
assuming now how's that kind of I think
so far it's working I I don't know if we
need the clarification is I is it
limited to just Steve may know better
than I do is it limited to just
electricians or do does anybody else
have a one-year apprenticeship right now
I I think we're the only that have the
one year they have single year but they
let I think mechanical lets it go for
two years or doesn't doesn't really
check ours just says you got to show
that you've done the schooling before
you can get it again it's always been
that way so we just if you give it to
your license since they don't actually
show they've done the schooling it's
going to really mess up that whole
process so right yeah I don't think
anybody's going to be
like well The Apprentice licensing well
see that's a good point Steve because
right now it's one year for that and
nobody's going to be like clamoring to
have to renew more often but if it's not
laid out in statutes somebody could
potentially start a licensing program
and have a way around it but then it it
would have to go through
rules correct and and wouldn't
if and I'm just asking if you leave it
like it is given the ability of somebody
else want to change it to that not
having to come back and do it as opposed
to just saying electrical apprentices it
gives them the ability to deal with any
apprentices throughout the oplc if they
change it so I would think it's best
just left like it is
but as long as we can address our issue
I'm not going to fight for everybody
else anything else do it' be a different
chapter for electrical than for any
other so it be different chapter but it
wouldn't be a wouldn't be a bad thing to
put the extra word in there so um I'll
just sort out there real quick again uh
because we're we're really laidback
during this subcommittee meeting still
just come through the chair because so I
don't jump over people I just I'm sorry
I have to go I'm still working on that
being in two places at once thing but I
haven't mastered it so I have to hop
back over to the state house any other
question yes my name is Courtney
Tanner we have it here I can I can in
touch with you if I do text me call me
email me thank you for getting the
information you did it was very helpful
absolutely thank you so much thank you
for your work on this
yep ad you said you were on your way
the technically she was late but that's
okay thank you Courtney appreciate it
um any anything else on the language
that proposed in this amendment I think
it's cleaner than the original Bill
personally
um I'm not sure that it I'm not sure it
actually changes anything I'm not 100%
sure Doug do you have thoughts on what
it was changing there was one thing in
there what was it that I felt like was
different well Doug you're going to be
looking at this right you're going to be
looking at this and if
any thoughts occur to you you'll get
back to us yes there I I don't know if
you want to move on but I did want a
flag and you and I had discussed it in
the Senate right now um House Bill 1622
and House Bill 518 both have bills that
are amending this same paragraph so
right now we have three bills amending
the same paragraph my recommendation in
the Senate was to pull it out of 1622
and just move that language over to 518
but now we've also got this to contend
with if their decision here I could also
potentially work this language into that
and just get it all in one place
depending on the decisions made um just
putting that out there because we've got
it we've got three we've got three bills
with three different RSA 3108 paragraph
twos sure so what you're saying as
opposed to pushing SP 371 through just
take the language attach it to are both
of those bills in the Senate both of
those bills in the Senate right I don't
understood uh um the other thing I could
do is grab the language from that we
worked on with doj for
1622 and we could drop it in here and I
could just put this language the problem
the things are the only well the only
other thing to take into consideration
is the potential for adding the other
language that you that we've talked
about um which would which would be a
standalone Bill we have to have a public
hearing on it if we do
this would fit in with that
um maybe if we can just make sure that
we work together to make sure the
language doesn't conflict in its final
okay state that and I'll just put
together one paragraph that kind of
merges the three sure and then we should
be in a good place okay um because I did
want to give some consideration
to um and we'll talk to Lindsay about it
but I do want to give some consideration
to a price adjustment if we if we go
ahead with this
um just so that it's reasonable um we'll
be saving them time but you know they'll
be deferring the costs for other
providers
um any other comments at this
point
from you coordinate yeah is anybody just
flat out against the
idea of of opening up this exception for
Resident
Physicians okay so the subcommittee is
working under the assumption that we're
as a subcommittee we're okay with the
overall concept of the bill we just have
those few things that we may want to
work in then we'll call another
subcommittee meeting with a with an
amendment we can take a look at an
official Amendment and go from there no
no I want because I'm nodding but I
can't see whether I can't see whether
I wanted to get your attention because
you were looking that
dire okay very good well then I will say
that we'll move in that direction seeing
that there's no evidence of harm being
caused by the longer licensing over time
um it doesn't it doesn't seem like it's
there's any reason not to do that it is
kind of a unique set of
circumstances um as long as we in my
opinion as long as we're willing to
adjust the licensing fee component of it
to be
accurate um unless Lindsay has something
to say about that that I'm unaware of uh
and then we'll probably just SP for your
edification um we have other language
coming uh that oplc has recommended we
may have a public hearing on and attach
it to this it's not in any way going to
be something that's going to put this at
risk so um it's pretty General stuff
language fixes and things of that nature
so well and
Steve yeah the four of us oh
Sor we we really appreciate your support
on this thank
you all right guys end of that and we've
got an hour and a half until regular